[Music]
it's a sight to see cardi b is taking
over la's pride parade
[Music]
you [ __ ] we all want to party with
cardi after she made a surprise
appearance at west hollywood's pride
celebrations over the weekend
[Applause]
cardi is giving her fans whip shots from
her personal line of whipped cream
infused with vodka oh yes honey cardi
looks like she's living it up and of
course the waff rapper had to give fans
a show twerking with drag queens from an
all-white float
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
we can't get over how stunning she looks
dressed in a rainbow jumpsuit with a
matching colorful bob you are drippin
pride month is a full month honoring
lgbtq culture and uplifting queer voices
and cardi wasn't the only celeb in
attendance
[Music]
janelle monae served as grand marshal in
a risque black and white outfit jojo
siwa mj rodriguez and more stars
gathered for the fun festivities to show
their own pride
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
still we think no one had more fun than
cardi fans
[Music]
you